[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і давайте
більше розважатися з англійською, доброго ранку, Павле,
як справи, я фантастичний, тому що сьогодні
ми знову дізнаємося про Великобританію,
так багато уроків про Великобританію
та Пола сьогодні  ми будемо говорити про
винаходи, добре, Павле, чи
можете ви придумати якісь винаходи, які
дійсно важливі для людства.
Я повинен сказати, що ескалатор, очевидно,
старі люди не можуть ходити, а люди з
обмеженими можливостями не можуть ходити, а також
ескалатори в  Київ — це так довго
для мене чудова вправа, щоб бігти на їх вершині
так, ви маєте на увазі, що ескалатор на нашому
метро в кінотеатрі величезний,
так, найглибша станція метро в
світі, так, але якщо ви заглибитесь
у століття,
що є найважливішим  винаходи я
б взяв
кермо  добре,
хлопці, тож давайте зануримося в тему
трошки глибше, тому першою частиною
вашого домашнього завдання буде перегляд цього
відео, прикріпіть посилання на
відео YouTube, щоб у вас була ця
інтерактивна гра, вам потрібно буде вибрати
режими  ви можете грати в казино і навіть
покласти пояси, і тоді ви дізнаєтеся більше
про винаходи, а тепер
повернемося до Великобританії, добре, отже, п'ять найкращих
британських винаходів, які змінюють світ
Пол, чи можете ви пригадати будь-який з них, які
я пам'ятаю в школі, що ми зробили  багато-
багато вивчав про потяги і про
те, що ви знаєте, Кріс винайшов
парові двигуни потягів, так, добре, і
я пам'ятаю, що мій батько розповідав мені
замість сну казки замість
казок, які він розповідав мені про
теорію часу  Стівен Хокінг,
тому для мене немає оповідань на ніч, але багато
фізики все одно було справді цікаво,
давайте подивимося,
щоб вони прочитали це п'ять найкращих британських
винаходів, і перший з них - це час,
Пол, чому так добре, ви ніколи не можете отримати  t
час назад, як тільки ви використали свій час,
ви не можете його замінити, тому час має
важливе значення в житті, але чи це британський
винахід, я не знав, що це
винахід Великобританії, однак я був у
соборі Солсбері в графстві Вілтшир в
Англії  і у них є одні з найстаріших
годинників у світі, це
місце, яке вони називають Грінвіч, Грінвіч,
це найбільший середній час, це важливо
для всього світу, і коли ми говоримо
про зелений колір, насправді це
винахід британців, які вони винайшли
свого роду  те, що зараз ми маємо однаковий
час, тому що до 1800 різних
місць по всьому світу враховували свій
власний час
відповідно до сходу і
заходу Сонця, а тоді не було універсальних
часових рамок, щоб з'єднати всі
міста різних країн, так і вчені
у Грінвічській обсерваторії
в 1884 році змінили все це і встановили єдиний
Всесвітній час для всього світу, тож
хіба це не фантастично, так, і я там був,
у цьому місці велика черга
в Грінвічі, і ви можете поставити одну ногу
на один бік, одну ногу на інший
бік, щоб ви перебували на сході, ліворуч
, на заході і на заході, ніби перебуваючи
в двох півкулях, два часових пояси
перебувають у двох часових поясах одночасно
в той же час це цікаво,
добре, давайте рухатися далі, а другий - це
парова машина так, ви були цілком праві,
чому це так важливо, тому що це було
під час або в основному було одним
із каталізаторів промислової
революції, так, тому промислова революція не була
б  не сталося, якби цього і
Жана не винайшли по праву, ймовірно,
не так, і насправді це вплинуло не
тільки на Британські острови, це
знову вплинуло на весь світ, тому що воно
відкрило горизонти, воно розширило горизонти
і прискорило розвиток промисловості та торгівлі
та міжнародного розвитку  торгівля стала можливою
, і перший комерційно життєздатний
паровий поршневий двигун був розроблений Томом
You Comin приблизно в 1712 році, чи
можете ви уявити собі більше трьох
століть тому і
ngine визначив епоху транспортних
інновацій і поставив світ у
колиску промислової революції, і
знову ж таки він дозволив нам подорожувати швидше,
добре, то що таке наступний винахід, що
ви думаєте про винахід Великобританії,
можливо, папір, папір без паперу  це китайський
винахід, а наступний -
електричний портал, яка різниця
між двигуном і геном. Я думаю, що
двигун - це те, що ви могли б мати
у вашій пральній машині,
так, де двигун, очевидно, приводить в дію
автомобіль так, і для двигуна, який вам потрібен
бензин або якесь інше паливо, але
для двигуна потрібна електрика, так,
а інший винахід Великобританії - це
розробка електродвигуна, і він
був результатом сотень важливих
наукових експериментів і відкриттів,
і насправді його винайшов Майкл
Фарадей в
18  :21 ну, хлопці, два століття тому дуже-
дуже давно, і його експерименти
продемонстрували, як електричний заряд
можна використовувати для стимуляції механічного
руху.  і це проклало свій шлях до
всієї історії електроніки чи можете ви
повірити, що всі гаджети, які ми маємо зараз,
усі пральні машини, і я
все, що у нас є вдома, започатковано ще
в 1821 році Майклом Фарадеєм і його
винаходом електродвигуна, добре
наступний, о, ти мене сьогодні добре випробовуєш,
йога, можливо, парашут,
парашут, це дуже гарний
винахід, але ми будемо говорити про
дороги, о, дороги, з якими я воював, римляни
винайшли дороги так, римляни
винайшли дороги і є  багато римських
доріг у Британії, вони все ще асфальтовані, і
ви можете по них пішки або навіть їздити,
так, у Великобританії є дуже довга римська дорога, яка
тягнеться на сотні миль, але
яка різниця між цією дорогою,
яку ви бачите на малюнку, і  Римська
дорога, ви не можете їхати на машині по
Римській дорозі, так, ви можете просто пройтися по
підвісці, і колеса можуть бути такими ж поганими,
як і всі діри на київських дорогах, можливо,
добре, так що давайте подивимося, так, це свого роду
поштовх, щоб сказати, що br.  Ітанці винайшли
дороги, але вони винайшли щось
інше, вони винайшли дорожню
конструкцію, як ми її знаємо сьогодні, ви
знаєте, що вона має різні шари, як
мурашині, вона повинна мати твердий кам'яний шар,
ніж вона покрита м'якою поглинаючою
поверхнею, і це було винайдено
шотландським інженером  Джон Макадам і
протягом 18 століття знову багато
століть тому, і ці дороги, ймовірно
, були навіть кращими, ніж ті, які ми маємо
сьогодні
всі німецькі автомагістралі мають сказати
спасибі шотландському інженеру, якого ви бачите, щоб
німці, у вас не було б
ідеальних доріг без шотландського
інженера Джона Макадама, добре, я наступний
винахід, я був неправий, так що,
можливо, давайте  скажімо, мікрохвильова
піч добре я знаю, що британці
в основному були першими, хто використовував їх
після Другої світової війни, але ми
збираємося говорити про те, що
ніхто  y уявляє своє життя без
цього всесвітньої мережі,
і знову сюди приходять британці
зі своїми винаходами та своєю
творчістю, щоб бути дуббі дуббі ви
чули, що весь час правильно мм-хм,
так чи можна жити без дуббі
dubby dubby ні не неможливо Ольга так,
навіть цей проект, навіть ця школа
, не була б можлива без
всесвітньої мережі, тому що ви, ймовірно,
дивитеся на нас на YouTube, добре, і тому
батько сучасного цифрового ландшафту,
який англійський вчений з інформатики, і його
звуть Тім  Бернерс-Лі та він
створили перший веб-браузер у 1989 році, тож
скільки років тому насправді почалося це 31
рік 31 рік тому я трохи
старший, але це дійсно давно, і
всесвітню мережу не слід плутати
з Інтернетом, це щось
інакше, і ми будемо більше говорити
про daba daba daba добре, тому наступне
завдання полягає в тому, що нам знадобиться деякий словниковий запас
для аудіювання, яке ми матимемо під час
цього уроку, тож давайте подивимося на
ці слова та те, що для мене цікаво,
у цьому слові ви можете побачити слово
пристрій,
але ви можете побачити артикль. Я зазвичай
використовую його як дієслово, щоб розділити щось, але
тут це іменник, тому Павле, що ви
думаєте, що таке розділити щось
розділяє дві речі добре, а потім
прийди, щоб помиритися.
Я знаю, що макіяж любить робити
гарне обличчя гримуватися
зараз, коли, можливо, у вас буде сварка
з чоловіком наступного дня, ви
знову станете друзями, так, ви помиритесь
з  люди після суперечки, але, можливо
, є щось інше,
тоді приходить Універсальний, його можна використовувати для
багатьох цілей мм-хм, тож як універсальну
мову, наприклад, чи можна англійську
назвати універсальною мовою, я думаю, що
це найуніверсальніша мова мм-хм,
потім приходить абстрактна  це складно
, можливо, це щось не є
нормою,
так, коли я бачу слово абстрактний,
я думаю про Пікассо та його картини
добре, тоді приходить розчарування, чи можете ви назвати
цей синонім я розчарований, це
проблема  Одна Ольга це як
поєднання кількох слів, можливо, сумно
розчарований підкреслив, що ти не можеш
виконати завдання
так, відразу, щоб добре, а потім приходить
нечіткое так, тому якщо ти задасте мені запитання, я
його не розумію, я можу сказати добре, чи
можна  дайте мені більше ясності, тому що ви
не вказали достатньо деталей у своєму
питанні, добре, а потім з'являється мережа,
яка схожа на всесвітню мережу або як у
вас є коло друзів, так багато
людей пов'язано, наприклад,
добре спілкуватися в мережі, і останнє  один
проти цього, як у вас є
змагання з місяць або близько того щоразу,
коли вона буде грати когось Челсі
проти добре хлопців, тепер ви готові
зіставити визначення слів, щоб
їм насправді все гаразд, тож давайте подивимося на
перше  порівняйте це з чи проти,
щоб на вашу думку, яка з них є правильною
відповіддю, і це протиставляється пробному стовпу так
так так
добре наступне велика система, що складається з
багатьох частин, які з'єднані разом,
і хлопців, які утворюють мережу так, давайте
йти  до наступного  e і створити велику
річ або число з маленьких речей на
числах, це означає створити так, не
тільки бути друзями, а й побудувати
щось, просто щоб зробити велику річ з
числа з менших, після того як ви
їх розділите, а потім ви отримаєте те, що
побудуйте так, щоб ви могли побачити, що цей
фразовий дієслово має різні значення,
принаймні, тепер ви знаєте три: зробити
гарне обличчя, зробити макіяж, щоб намалювати
, щоб знову почати дружити,
і третій, щоб зробити велику річ або
кілька речей з  менші у мене
є четвертий, який не ви
не брешете, але ви придумуєте історію
виправдань, так, а четвертий із pull
ви бачите одне слово для значень добре,
наступне грає роздратований або засмучений, тому що
ви не можете досягти того, що ви  хочу і
Пол, як ти сказав, це розчарування, добре,
наступне слово щось, що існує
як ідея, а не реальна річ, яку можна побачити і
доторкнутися
я не можу торкнутися деяких абстрактних речей, таких як
дружба або кохання, вони абстрактні,
добре, наступне різниця  або
відокремлення  n це роздільник так, тому я
щось поділю я можу щось розділити
я щось розділив, а ось розділити
це може бути і іменник, і дієслово okay
і давайте далі не дуже чітко або
детально Павло це дуже нечітко, і ви
можете побачити слово  і зверніть увагу на
вимову ще раз Пол нечітко
невизначено добре, давайте продовжимо і існуємо
скрізь, і для всіх
це універсальний Універсальний для всіх
Англійська мова відкрита для всіх добре, тому
ми готові до завдання аудіювання, хлопці,
ви повинні перевірити своє розуміння
під час слухання, а ви  потрібно сказати
, правдиві чи хибні речення.
Павло надасть вам завдання на аудіювання,
тому будьте обережні, слухаючи
його, і ви зможете почути, що вони
слухають двічі, перш ніж Павло почне
слухати завдання,
давайте прочитаємо всі ці твердження, які у вас є
сказати, правдиві вони чи невірні,
добре, тому перший HTTP – це
мова комп’ютера, яка робить Інтернет
можливим, можливо, ви знаєте це зі своїх
загальних знань, але якщо  ви не
слухаєте уважно, королева Англії
надіслала перший в історії електронний лист. Вау,
можливо, це правда, ми побачимо, що Тім
Бернерс-Лі вважає, що його винахід
близький до досконалості, тому це
означає, що йому досить комфортно
і  задоволений своїм винаходом номера
для Тіма Бернерса-Лі довелося винайти гіператаки,
перш ніж він міг винайти
всесвітню мережу, він знає цей гіпертекст, коли він,
коли ви можете клацнути, а потім переведе вас
на потрібний вам веб-сайт, номер п'ять,
він створив  Інтернет, тому що вчені з
CERN не любили спілкуватися один з одним,
щоб ділитися ідеями, чи
можете ви уявити собі багато інтровертів в
одному місці, які не люблять спілкуватися один з
одним, а потім з'явився винахід, можливо,
це правда, можливо, це не керівник Бернерса-Лі
не дуже позитивно ставився
до ідеї Інтернету, коли хтось
щось винаходить, звісно, є лю
и, які не вірять у цей ви
ахід, тоді приходить номер сім, ви
ільше не можете відвідувати першу веб-сто
рінку, правда це чи ні  що  це була
перша наша веб-сторінка, яку
ми побачимо, і остання, на якій ООН і
Тім Бернерс-Лі поділяють подібний план
щодо всесвітньої мережі, можливо, ідея
величезної організації така сама, як ідея однієї
людини. Добре, хлопці, ви готові  для
частини аудіювання, тож уважно подивіться на
речення та перевірте, як ви розумієте,
що Інтернет та всесвітня мережа
Інтернет – це не
одне й те саме, тоді сумнівайтеся,
що Інтернет існує з
початку 1970-х років на 20 років довше, ніж  веб
це в основному величезна мережа, що складається з
менших мереж комп’ютерів,
всесвітня мережа побудована на вершині
Інтернету, це спосіб обміну
інформацією у вигляді веб-сторінок
за допомогою свого роду комп’ютерної мови, яка називається
HTTP, тому ви часто податкове управління  запустити HTTP
вперед косу риску вперед косу риску www, бо
ненавидить TTP - це мова, а www
означає всесвітню мережу, до речі, ніхто не
знає, чому веб-адреса використовується для
статусу, а крапки навіть
винахідник мережі  Тім Бернерс-Лі каже, що ці
прямі косі риски насправді не потрібні,
і якби він міг повернутися в часі на 30
років і знову винайти всесвітню мережу,
він би позбавив їх
початку всесвітньої мережі в 1989 році,
коли британський вчений Тім Бернерс  -Лі
винайшов Інтернет, він працював у CERN
у Швейцарії, у них були комп'ютери,
звичайно, електронна пошта вже існувала, королева
Єлизавета II надіслала електронний лист у 1976 році,
ідея веб-адреси доменних імен
показує назву організації, до якої
вони належать, як Британська Рада
Dot org також існувала, вони використовували гіпертекст
для переходу від одного документа до іншого, але
жодна з цих речей не була разом, тому
вони не були дуже корисними, Бернерс Лі був
розчарований у ЦЕРН,
оскільки всі вчені мали різні
типи комп’ютерів, з якими не могли
спілкуватися  один одного, якщо ви хотіли отримати інформацію,
ви повинні були пам’ятати, на якому саме
комп’ютері була ця інформація, і
знати, як використовувати спеціальні програми
для цього комп’ютера. Бернерс-Лі мав
ідея уявної інформаційної системи,
яку кожен може прочитати, він написав
звіт, у якому запропонував спосіб об’єднати
доменні імена Інтернету та
гіпертекст в одну систему. Його ідея була настільки
абстрактною, що його керівник назвав її розпливчастою,
але захоплюючою через два роки, у
1980-1991 роках.  перший у світі веб-сайт був створений
в CERN HTTP чотири косої лінії, чотири косої риски інформація
CERN точка CH Сайт, який ви можете побачити зараз,
є копією, створеною в 1992 році, цифровий розрив
сьогодні 30 років потому, ця ідея більше
не є розпливчастою, і це частина
повсякденної реальності багатьох людей.  Інтернет
з'єднує близько 55 відсотків населення світу
з рештою світу
через Інтернет, але оскільки лише половина
світу підключена, існує цифровий
розрив між спільнотами з регулярним
доступом до Інтернету та тими, хто не
має доступу до Інтернету в Північній Америці, 95 відсотків людей мають
доступ до Інтернету  і так само 85%
європейців порівнюють це з Азією, де
лише половина населення має доступ
до Інтернету, і з Африкою на 36% у
деяких країнах.  У розвинених країнах молоді
люди мають більше шансів бути в
Інтернеті, ніж люди похилого віку.
Організація Об’єднаних Націй каже, що
найменш розвинені країни світу матимуть
універсальний доступ до Інтернету до 2020 року, вони
очікують досягти цього за допомогою
недорогих послуг мобільного зв’язку, які
включають  Інтернет – це ключ до
припинення цифрового розриву, коли
Інтернет доступний для всіх, як
уявляв Тім Бернерс-Лі, люди в усьому світі
можуть насолоджуватися соціальними освітніми та
економічними перевагами, які він приносить
добре хлопці, яких ви слухаєте вперше,
можливо, ви готові відзначити  деякі
речення
добре, прогляньте їх ще раз, позначте
їх, і тоді ви зможете прослухати
їх ще раз, добре, тож
вам буде час подумати в Інтернеті
проти всесвітньої мережі Інтернет та
Інтернет не зовсім  те ж саме, тоді
сумнівайтеся, що
Інтернет існує з початку 1970-х років на двадцять
років довше, ніж Інтернет, це в
основному величезна мережа, божевільна  Більше менших
комп’ютерних мереж, всесвітня
мережа побудована на вершині Інтернету,
це спосіб обміну інформацією у
вигляді веб-сторінок за допомогою свого роду
комп’ютерної мови, яка називається HTTP
, тому urs часто запускає HTTP пряму
косу риску www  оскільки HTTP –
це мова, а www означає
всесвітню павутину, до речі, ніхто не знає, чому веб-
адреса використовується для похилих рисків і
крапок, навіть винахідник мережі Тім
Бернерс-Лі каже, що ці прямі косі риски
насправді не потрібні, і він, якби
міг  поверніться в минуле на тридцять років і
знову винайшов всесвітню мережу, він
потім виніс би їх початок
всесвітньої мережі в 1989 році, коли британський
вчений Тім Бернерс-Лі винайшов
мережу, на якій він працював у CERN у
Швейцарії, у них, звичайно, були комп’ютери
електронна пошта вже існувала queen elizabeth
ii надіслала електронного листа в 1976 році, ідея
веб-адреси доменних імен показує
назву організації, до якої вони належать,
як також існує Британська Рада.
d вони використовували гіпертекст для переходу від
одного документа до іншого, але жодна з
цих речей не працює разом,
і вони не були дуже корисними, Бернерс Лі
був розчарований у ЦЕРН, оскільки всі
вчені мали різні типи
комп’ютерів, які не могли спілкуватися один з
одним, якщо  ви хотіли отримати інформацію, ви повинні
були пам’ятати, на якому саме комп’ютері була ця
інформація, і знати, як
використовувати спеціальні програми для цього комп’ютера.
об'єднати доменні імена в Інтернеті та гіпертекст в
одну систему, його ідея була настільки абстрактною, що
його керівник назвав її розпливчастою, але захоплюючою через
два роки в 1980 1991 перший у
світі веб-сайт був створений в CERN HTTP
чотири косої частини інформації CERN точка
CH сайт, який ви  зараз можна побачити копію, зроблену
в 1992 році, цифровий розрив сьогодні 30
років потому, що ця ідея більше не є невизначеною,
і це частина повсякденної реальності багатьох людей
Інтернет-з'єднання  Приблизно 55
відсотків населення світу звертається до
решти світу через Інтернет, але
оскільки лише половина світу підключена до Інтернету,
існує цифровий розрив між
спільнотами, які мають регулярний доступ до Інтернету,
і тими, хто не має доступу до Інтернету в Північній Америці, 95
відсотків людей мають доступ до Інтернету
та  тож 85% європейців
порівнюють це з Азією, де лише
половина населення має доступ до Інтернету, і з
Африкою (36%) у деяких
найменш розвинених країнах молоді люди
мають більше шансів бути в Інтернеті,
ніж літні люди.
розвинені країни матимуть
універсальний доступ до Інтернету до 2020 року, вони
очікують досягти цього за допомогою
недорогих послуг мобільного зв’язку, які
включають Інтернет, це ключ до
припинення цифрового розриву, коли
Інтернет доступний для всіх, як Тім
Бернерс-Лі  уявні люди в усьому світі
можуть насолоджуватися соціальними освітніми та
економічними перевагами, які це приносить,
хлопці, так ви готові  добре перевірте своє
розуміння, це була величезна
кількість інформації, але це було справді
цікаво, тому перший HTTP, це
мова комп’ютера, правда чи неправда,
хлопці, це правда, це мова комп’ютера
друге речення, яке
королева Англії надіслала вперше в історії
Пол, ви пам’ятаєте дату, я
пам’ятаю цю дату, тому що це був один
із найспекотніших років у Великобританії в
1976 році, у нас було дуже спекотне літо 1976 року, і
дуже спекотне літо, і королева Англії
надіслала перший електронний лист, тому ця
заява  false, чому це невірно, тому що ми
не знаємо, чи вона була першою,
хто надіслав електронний лист, але все одно це було дуже
давно, добре, наступне речення,
якщо винахідник вважає, що його
винахід настільки близький до досконалості, наскільки це можливо, і
насправді твердження помилкове, спочатку він був
розчарований, і йому довелося внести
багато змін, наступного разу Тім
Бернерс-Лі довелося винайти гіпертекст,
перш ніж це правда чи неправда,
це твердження хибне
гіпертекст alrea  dy існував, і вони використовували
його для навігації з різних документів Word,
і все одно йому не потрібно було
винаходити його номер п'ять, він створив Інтернет,
тому що вчені ЦЕРН не
хотіли розмовляти один з одним, і насправді
це не було причиною того, що  допомогли
вченим говорити, але це були не
ті вчені, які не хотіли говорити,
це були їхні комп'ютери, вони всі мали
різні системи, і вони не могли
спілкуватися, машини не могли
спілкуватися не люди, у яких ми
говоримо англійською, коли ви  різні
системи зв'язуються, це називається "
вітальною сумісністю", тому вони не
сумісні так, так що комп'ютери,
машини були несумісні, не
люди
номер шість, його бос
не був повністю позитивним, давайте подивимося, і
це правда,
добре, номер сім, ви більше не можете
відвідувати перший  - коли-небудь веб-сторінка, чи це правда,
це правда, що ви більше не можете так, так,
так що ви більше не можете відвідати
першу сторінку, яку ви можете відвідати, копію
цієї веб-сторінки ООН і Тім Берн  ers-lee
поділяють подібний план, тому це правда, що їх
бачення полягає в тому, що всі мають
підключення до Інтернету та користуються
всесвітньою мережею Я бачу добре, хлопці, тому я сподіваюся, що
ви досить добре впоралися з цим завданням, тому хлопці,
вам сподобався урок, власні винаходи I
Сподіваюся, ви це зробили під час проведення цього уроку, я
провів величезне дослідження, і насправді ця
презентація є моїм проектом про британські
винаходи, ми хочемо, щоб ви зробили свій власний
проект про будь-який з британських винаходів,
ви можете взяти ті, які ми обговорювали
на початку, наприклад час або дороги
і налаштуйте проект на них, знайдіть
інші британські винаходи, які
змінили світ, і створіть свій власний, це може
бути будь-який вид, це може бути відеопроект,
це може бути презентація PowerPoint або
будь-яка інша презентація будь-якого виду, який ви
знаєте і любите робити  добре, хлопці, будьте
креативними, будьте інноваційними та створюйте кілька
винаходів так, і є багато сучасних
винаходів, які ви можете вибрати не
лише з давніх-
давен, добре, хлопці, слідкуйте за оновленнями та до
зустрічі  час до побачення
[Музика]
ти